Hey there, it's Marianne here. If you've been thinking about creating a sustainable, scalable income stream, now could well be the time to take action. My mentor Lisa Johnson has just opened the doors to her one-to-many program, the exact system that helps you turn your knowledge into recurring revenue. It only opens once a year and now's the time. And when you join Via My Link, you will unlock exclusive bonuses worth over 800 pounds, designed to support you every step of the way. They are in addition to Lisa's existing bonuses too.
大家好，我是Marianne。如果你一直在考虑创造一个可持续、可扩展的收入来源，现在正是采取行动的好时机。我的导师Lisa Johnson刚刚开放了她的“一对多”项目，这正是帮助你将知识转化为经常性收入的系统。它每年只开放一次，现在就是时候了。通过我的链接加入，你将解锁价值超过800英镑的独家赠品，旨在为你提供全程支持。这些赠品也是Lisa现有赠品之外的额外福利。
So this is your chance to get expert guidance and take control of your financial future without waiting years to figure it all out. Doors close at 10 p. Monday 10th March 2025 UK time, so grab your spot now via my linktree, Dr Mary Ann Trent, my social media or just drop me a DM. Don't forget all of my brilliant bonuses that you can check out in the links are in addition to Lisa's great bonuses too. Right, let's crack on with the episode. to Lisa's great bonuses too. Right, let's crack on with the episode.
所以，这是你获得专家指导并掌控自己财务未来的机会，不必再等上几年去摸索。报名将于英国时间2025年3月10日周一晚上10点截止，所以现在就通过我的Linktree、Dr Mary Ann Trent社交媒体或直接给我发私信来抢占名额吧。别忘了，你可以在链接中查看我所有精彩的赠品，它们也是Lisa丰厚赠品之外的额外福利。好了，让我们开始这一集吧。
Are you considering a career in psychology later in life, but unsure if it's too late? Spoiler alert, it's not. In fact, your life experiences can give you a unique edge. Today, we are diving into the practical steps, the challenges, and the incredible opportunities for older applicants who might either be starting or continuing their journey into psychology.
你是否在考虑在人生后期从事心理学职业，但又不确定是否太晚了？剧透一下，并不晚。事实上，你的人生阅历可以赋予你独特的优势。今天，我们将深入探讨对于那些可能正在开始或继续其心理学之旅的年长申请者来说，切实可行的步骤、挑战以及不可思议的机遇。
Stay tuned as we explore why it's never too late to follow your calling. Hi, welcome along to the Aspiring Psychologist podcast. I'm Dr. Marianne and I'm a qualified clinical psychologist. Now today's episode has been born out of lots of people contacting me via the DMs, talking about how lovely it is to be shining a light on how important it is to consider diversifying our workforce, but also, you know also really supporting the needs of older applicants. And please don't tune out if you are a younger applicant, because this is still relevant for you.
请继续收听，我们将探讨为什么追随你的使命永远不会太晚。嗨，欢迎来到《有抱负的心理学家》播客。我是Marianne博士，我是一名合格的临床心理学家。今天这一集源于许多人通过私信联系我，谈到能够聚焦于考虑劳动力多元化的重要性，以及真正支持年长申请者的需求是多么美好。如果你是年轻的申请者，请不要关掉，因为这对你依然有意义。
This is about how you can support others in your workforce, in your teams, perhaps people you will meet as you're a trainee. Could be people in admin teams currently who feel inspired by the work that you do in your department and what your journey is like. So please do stay tuned because there's so much to gain from this episode, whatever your age. So you may already have watched the episode I did with Thomas Gourley. The title of the
这关乎你如何支持劳动力队伍中的其他人、你的团队，或者可能是你在实习期间遇到的人。这可能是目前行政团队中那些被你在部门所做的工作以及你的旅程所激励的人。所以请务必收听，因为无论你多大年纪，都能从这一集中获得很多收获。你可能已经看过我与Thomas Gourley合作的那一集了。那一集的标题是
episode was How to Start a Psychology Career in Your 30s and beyond. And that is my most popular psychology episode ever on YouTube with at the time of recording almost 3,000 views. So this is clearly something that is resonating with you. We've also spoken with Gavin about his experience of being a slightly older applicant and doing a conversion masters. So that's a really good one to watch as well. And of course, we spoke to Rose quite early on in our journey about
《如何在30岁及以后开启心理学职业生涯》。那是目前我在YouTube上最受欢迎的心理学视频，录制时已有近3000次观看。所以这显然是引起了你们共鸣的话题。我们还与Gavin聊过他作为稍年长的申请者并攻读转换硕士学位的经历。所以那也是非常值得一看的。当然，我们在旅程早期也和Rose聊过
her experience of already being a parent. So not necessarily super much older than the rest of her cohort at that time, but you know, more life experienced in that she already has children during training. And more recently, we've been thinking about the affordability of aspiring psychologist roles, such as an assistant psychologist, especially if you're an older applicant. That was a really interesting chat that I had with Sam, who is a trained counselor and also ideally wants to get onto the paid NHS doctorate. Wherever you are here, listening or watching, you are so welcome and I hope that you will find this
她作为一名母亲的经历。所以她当时并不一定比同龄人年长很多，但你知道，她在培训期间已经有了孩子，生活阅历更丰富。最近，我们一直在思考有抱负的心理学家职位的负担能力，比如助理心理学家，特别是如果你是一名年长的申请者。那是我与Sam进行的一次非常有趣的谈话，她是一名受过培训的咨询师，也理想地希望进入带薪的NHS博士课程。无论你在哪里收听或观看，都非常欢迎你，我希望你会发现
to be some inspiration, some advice, some insights into what could be a life-changing path for you and for those that you end up working with. So our first point to explore is why would someone consider a psychology career later in life? I think it's really important that we think about breaking that myth of it's too late, you know, I'm too old. So I think we really need to really take a look at that myth, you know, of it being too late. Is it ever too late?
这为你以及你最终与之共事的人提供了一些灵感、建议和洞察，这可能是一条改变人生的道路。所以我们要探讨的第一个点是，为什么有人会在人生后期考虑心理学职业？我认为思考打破“太晚了”、“我太老了”这种迷思非常重要。所以我认为我们真的需要审视一下“太晚了”这个迷思。真的太晚了吗？
Do we need to listen to that narrative at all? And I think sometimes case studies can be really, really interesting and really inspiring. You know, when we see it, we can be it. And so I want to be part of that narrative, helping to shed light on the fact that older applicants are being successful and we've seen that during my podcasts already but let's have a look at the data the equal opportunities data that's provided by the clearinghouse. I can only find the 2023 entry data at the moment but it might well be that the 2024 entry data is coming and as and when it does you, perhaps I'll do another episode on that. So let me know if you'd find that helpful. If you are on MP3, then please do connect with me
我们需要听从那种叙事吗？我认为有时案例研究会非常非常有趣且鼓舞人心。你知道，当我们看到它时，我们就能成为它。所以我想成为那种叙事的一部分，帮助阐明这样一个事实：年长的申请者正在取得成功，我们在我的播客中已经看到了这一点。但让我们看看数据，由Clearinghouse提供的平等机会数据。目前我只能找到2023年的入学数据，但很可能2024年的数据即将到来，届时我可能会再做一集。所以如果你觉得有帮助，请告诉我。如果你在听MP3，请务必在社交媒体上与我联系，
on socials or if you're on Spotify, you can drop a question or a comment in there too. So it may not come as any surprise that the biggest chunk of applicants is in the 25 to 29 year old category with 51.2% of applicants being in that age bracket. But if we're thinking about perhaps what starts to become maybe a slightly older applicant, certainly in my time on training, I think one person was 24,
或者如果你在Spotify上，也可以在那里留下问题或评论。所以，最大的申请群体是25至29岁这一类别，占申请者的51.2%，这可能并不令人惊讶。但如果我们考虑什么开始成为稍微年长的申请者，肯定在我培训期间，我想只有一个人是24岁，
everybody else bar five applicants was in the 25 to 29. Already the data is starting to become a little bit more top heavy, which I think is really exciting because I gained so much from the experience and the wisdom and I think also the compassionate nurturing of the people that were slightly older than me on the cohort.
除了五名申请者外，其他人都在25至29岁之间。数据已经开始变得有点“头重脚轻”，我认为这非常令人兴奋，因为我从比我稍年长的同龄人的经验、智慧，以及我认为还有他们的同情心和培育中获益良多。
So the data we're looking at is how many applicants are applying and how many applicants have been offered accepted places. So if we were to, for example, to look at the data for 30 to 34 year olds, which I think, you know, starts to be slightly older than average, then it was 687 people, which was 13.8% applied. 170 people were offered places and accepted. That was 14.4% of the places offered were actually for
所以我们正在查看的数据是申请人数以及有多少申请者获得了录取名额。例如，如果我们查看30至34岁人群的数据，我认为这开始比平均年龄稍大，那么有687人申请，占13.8%。170人获得了录取名额并接受了。这占所提供名额的14.4%，实际上是针对
people in the 30 to 34 years age bracket. So perhaps what's interesting there is that they also give us a column for percentage success of the applicants to be accepted and actually the 30 to 34 camp was 24.7% likelihood of being accepted which is only just below the 28% of the 25 to 29 year olds, which is quite exciting I think. For the 35 to 39 year olds in 2023, 275 people applied, which was 5.5%, 43 were offered places, but of course 15.6% chance of being accepted. So we're already starting to see that maybe there's something in the skills and experiences of our older applicants which is making them a little bit more likely to get places. In 2023 165 people who
30至34岁年龄段的人。所以也许有趣的是，他们还为我们提供了一列申请者被录取的成功百分比，实际上30至34岁阵营的录取可能性为24.7%，仅略低于25至29岁人群的28%，我认为这相当令人兴奋。对于2023年的35至39岁人群，275人申请，占5.5%，43人获得名额，当然有15.6%的录取机会。所以我们已经开始看到，也许我们年长申请者的技能和经验中确实有一些东西使他们更有可能获得名额。在2023年，165名
were 40 to 44 years applied and 20 of those were offered places. 45 to 49 year olds, 80 people applied which I love. I love that. This is so exciting to me. And nine of those were offered places. 50 to 54 years old, 25 people applied and similarly for 55 and over, 12 people applied. it looks like either none of those people were offered places or that they've grouped together the 45 to 49 or there's a sort of gap in the data. So I'm not quite sure what's happened with that. I would have hoped there'd be a zero if it was a zero. But I wonder if actually a really interesting point to consider here is maybe some of the
40至44岁的人申请，其中20人获得了名额。45至49岁，80人申请，我喜欢这个。我喜欢这一点。这对我来说太令人兴奋了。其中9人获得了名额。50至54岁，25人申请，55岁及以上也是类似，12人申请。看起来要么这些人都没有获得名额，要么他们把45至49岁归在一起了，或者数据中存在某种缺口。所以我不太确定发生了什么。如果结果是零，我本希望看到一个零。但我怀疑，这里一个非常值得考虑的有趣点可能是，也许一些
older applicants hadn't necessarily understood what the requirements were. Perhaps they hadn't done a conversion masters, perhaps they hadn't done enough relevant skills experience, perhaps the people they were asking to be references or suitability statements were not ideal. And so perhaps this kind of content is really helpful for everybody, people of all ages, to be able to really think about what experience they have, whether they meet the minimum requirements, because we can't know whether some of the people who are applying, you know, were kind of screened out at the first chance. And it might just be that because we have to report on the people who have applied, we might also be getting people that maybe haven't done the best applications or haven't fulfilled
年长的申请者并不一定理解要求是什么。也许他们没有完成转换硕士学位，也许他们没有足够的临床相关技能经验，也许他们要求提供推荐信或能力陈述的人并不理想。所以也许这种内容对每个人，所有年龄段的人都非常有帮助，能够真正思考他们拥有什么经验，是否满足最低要求，因为我们无法知道一些申请的人是否在第一轮就被筛选掉了。而且可能仅仅因为我们必须报告申请的人，我们可能也得到了一些可能没有做出最好申请或没有满足
the minimum requirements for application. So I don't mean to discredit anybody, older applicant or not, to suggest that you maybe haven't done the best of applications, but it could be a potential reason. I feel like I need to apologise if you can hear anything noisy. Someone has started doing some tree felling near me, which is always fun when you're on a podcast, right? So I think further breaking that taboo and thinking about it never being too late. For me, I speak as a 43 year old woman and I have children who are, I record 11 and 8 years of age and I've really noticed certainly over the last couple of years this idea of kind of a
申请最低要求的人。所以我并不是要诋毁任何人，无论是否是年长申请者，暗示你们可能没有做出最好的申请，但这可能是一个潜在原因。如果你们能听到任何嘈杂声，我觉得我需要道歉。有人开始在我附近砍树，当你做播客时这总是很有趣，对吧？所以我认为进一步打破禁忌并思考它永远不会太晚。对我来说，我以一名43岁女性的身份发言，我有孩子，录制时他们分别是11岁和8岁，我确实注意到了，特别是在过去几年里，这种“第二春”的想法。
second spring. I am out the other side of the very young and very exhausting parenting stage. My children were not sleepers. At worst, my eldest woke up 31 times a night and I was going to work so when I went back to work following my maternity leave for both children, sometimes they were waking 7 to 13 times a night really regularly and I was holding down you know either a four day a week job or a three day a week job with that level of chronic exhaustion. That really did take its toll on my available emotional resources really to be able to think about drive. And so if someone is
我已经走出了非常年幼且非常令人筋疲力尽的育儿阶段。我的孩子不睡觉。最糟糕的时候，我的大孩子一晚上醒来31次，而我还要去工作。所以当我休完两个孩子的产假回到工作岗位时，有时他们一晚上会醒来7到13次，非常频繁，而我还要在那种程度的慢性疲劳下维持一份每周四天或三天的工作。那确实对我的情感资源造成了损害，真的很难去思考动力。所以如果有人正处于
in that kind of tricky stage of their life, once things settle down, I think that's when this second spring idea comes around. And certainly it's over the last couple of years that I've been able to focus more time and more energy on other pursuits that interest me, like this podcast, like the Aspiring Psychologist membership, like writing and publishing books. And so if I was still the same age, still with my same husband, still with my same children, but I hadn't yet become a qualified psychologist, some of that energy, some of that, you know, striving and drive would and could have been
那种棘手的人生阶段，一旦事情安定下来，我认为这就是“第二春”想法出现的时候。当然，在过去几年里，我能够将更多的时间和精力集中在其他我感兴趣的追求上，比如这个播客，比如“有抱负的心理学家”会员计划，比如写作和出版书籍。所以如果我还是同样的年龄，还是同样的丈夫，还是同样的孩子，但我还没有成为一名合格的心理学家，那么我的一些精力，一些那种奋斗和动力，本来可以被我
used by me to focus on developing my career. So you may be watching this and I don't know what your gender is but whatever your gender is it might be that you're now at a stage where you know your dependents don't need you quite as much and perhaps hopefully your parents are healthy and so they're able to be kind of quite independent still. As I'm recording this my 75 year old mother is flying back from Vietnam after spending 10 days there so we're starting to really bust that myth of what age looks like and yes she is not pursuing a career in psychology and I don't know currently of anyone in their 70s who is doing that but if you are I
用来专注于发展我的职业生涯。所以你可能正在看这个，我不知道你的性别是什么，但无论你的性别是什么，可能你现在处于这样一个阶段：你的受抚养人不再那么需要你了，也许希望你的父母身体健康，所以他们仍然能够相当独立。在我录制这段话时，我75岁的母亲正在从越南飞回来，她在那里待了10天，所以我们开始真正打破年龄看起来是什么样的迷思。是的，她没有在追求心理学职业，我目前也不知道有任何70多岁的人在这样做，但如果你是，
would love to hear from you. But yeah, like age is just a number. If you're healthy, if you're happy, if you're thriving, you know, you have something to offer, so really, it's okay. If you've got the energy, if you've got the determination, and even if your parents or, you know, your children are not as independent as you would like them to be,
我很乐意收到你的来信。但是的，年龄只是一个数字。如果你健康，如果你快乐，如果你在茁壮成长，你知道，你就有东西可以提供，所以真的，没关系。如果你有精力，如果你有决心，即使你的父母或者你的孩子不像你希望的那样独立，
you might still be like, no, this is still right for me. I've got room for developing this psychology career in my life. And I, I salute you. So our second consideration are the practical steps. If you haven't already done a British Psychological Society approved undergraduate psychology degree or joint honors which confers that British Psychological Society approval. I'm obviously speaking from a UK perspective here. Then you will need to do a conversion masters that is approved by the British Psychological Society. They can be done as distance learning
你可能仍然会觉得，不，这对我来说依然是正确的。我的生活中还有发展这个心理学职业的空间。我向你致敬。所以我们的第二个考虑因素是切实可行的步骤。如果你还没有完成英国心理学会批准的心理学本科学位或联合荣誉学位，该学位授予了英国心理学会的认可。我显然是从英国的角度在这里发言。那么你需要完成一个由英国心理学会批准的转换硕士学位。它们可以作为远程学习
masters so you might still be able to work full-time or part-time around those. You don't necessarily have to kind of stop your life, stop your career, stop earning money, but of course you're going to need to be thinking about how you are going to do justice to that master's so that you do really well in it and how you're going to be able to weave in any research aspect of that masters too so that it fits in your life because what I know is when you're trying to fit too many things into you know a finite resource such as the 24 hours that you have in the day your well-being can take a really big hit and you know it might be that you have in the day, your well-being can take a really big hit. And you know, it might be
硕士学位来完成，所以你可能仍然能够兼顾全职或兼职工作。你不一定非要停止你的生活，停止你的职业，停止赚钱，但当然你需要考虑你将如何公正地对待那个硕士学位，以便你在其中表现出色，以及你将如何能够融入那个硕士学位的任何研究方面，以便它适合你的生活。因为我知道的是，当你试图把太多的事情塞进有限的资源中，比如你一天中拥有的24小时，你的幸福感可能会受到很大的打击，你知道，可能
that you can do that for a very fixed period of time. What I think is really useful to bear in mind is if we're thinking about a whole year or two years or maybe even three years, that is a big chunk of your life. And it might feel doable. You know, we think about it with commutes. You think, oh, I can commute, you know, 90 minutes each way. That'll be fine. Yeah, it might be fine for a week, but are you gonna wanna do that for three years? So we just need to be mindful. We really need to be tuning in to what's realistic,
你可以在一个非常固定的时间内做到这一点。我认为记住这一点非常有用：如果我们考虑整整一年或两年，甚至三年，那是你生命中很大的一部分。而且它可能感觉是可行的。你知道，我们想到通勤时。你会想，哦，我可以通勤，你知道，单程90分钟。那没问题。是的，这可能一周没问题，但你想坚持三年吗？所以我们只需要保持警惕。我们真的需要关注什么是现实的，
what's reasonable for us to do, for us to achieve, but also for those who might be supporting us around our home, around our families, around ourselves really, to asking them to put up with as well. But if you have an open frank conversation with those people and hopefully get their buy-in as well, that's a really great place to start. Please do catch up on the Gavin distance learning masters episode as well if that would be useful. Also as part of our practical steps considerations it's likely that you might well need to gain some more relevant clinical experience. Of course you might not be
什么是我们合理地去做、去实现的，但也包括那些可能在我们家里、在我们周围、在我们自己身边支持我们的人，要求他们忍受的事情。但如果你与这些人进行坦诚的对话，并希望也得到他们的支持，那是一个非常好的起点。如果有用的话，请务必补看Gavin的远程学习硕士那一集。同样，作为我们切实可行步骤考虑的一部分，你很可能需要获得更多相关的临床经验。当然，你可能不是
watching this as an aspiring clinical psychologist if you're for example an aspiring educational psychologist or forensic psychologist or a counselling psychologist. The same applies you're going to need some relevant experience. That usually involves being supervised by an HCPC practitioner psychologist, but not always. You don't always need to have had that, but it is advantageous because it really helps shape your thinking about the kind of work that you're doing and applies that psychology lens specifically to what you're doing. So those roles where you might find yourself working under qualified psychologists might be assistant psychologists, you know, could be psychological well-being practitioners, it could be that you're doing honorary work, although there's a whole can of worms that you
以有抱负的临床心理学家的身份观看这个视频，如果你例如是有抱负的教育心理学家、法医心理学家或咨询心理学家。同样适用，你需要一些相关的经验。这通常涉及由HCPC执业心理学家监督，但不总是这样。你不一定非要拥有那种经历，但它是有利的，因为它确实有助于塑造你对所做工作的思考，并将心理学视角具体应用于你所做的事情。所以那些你可能会发现自己在合格心理学家指导下工作的角色可能是助理心理学家，你知道，可能是心理健康从业者，可能是你在做荣誉工作，尽管这是一个你
could get into on that. There's another video, another episode that you can listen to on the considerations that we need to take on board for honorary roles. It might be that you're even working as a qualified CBT practitioner. Something that hopefully gives you access to a psychologist in your team or you're working closely with them is really usually the best way to help advance your skills. Of course people facing roles where you are working alongside people who are distressed or you know overcoming challenges like nursing can be really useful as well and you know that could be mental health nursing that could be physical health nursing and of course people in teaching
可能会陷入的麻烦。还有另一个视频，另一集你可以听听关于我们需要为荣誉角色考虑的事项。可能你甚至是一名合格的CBT从业者。希望这能让你接触到团队中的心理学家，或者你与他们密切合作，这通常是帮助提升你技能的最佳方式。当然，那些你与处于痛苦中的人一起工作，或者你知道，克服挑战的角色，比如护理，也非常有用，你知道，那可能是心理健康护理，那可能是身体健康护理，当然，从事教学的人
are uniquely placed to be able to think about making that leap to educational psychology but also sometimes to clinical psychology as well. When I was on my cohort we had someone who had previously been a teacher. We also had someone who had been a physical health nurse and it might be that you can go straight from your masters to apply and get places on your chosen doctorate course, but it might be that you need to do something where you are having more exposure to qualified psychologists too. And the step three of our point about practical steps is about the affordability of some of these routes. And of course, Sam's chat with me where we're thinking about whether assistant
处于独特的地位，能够考虑向教育心理学迈出那一步，有时也向临床心理学迈出那一步。当我在我的同龄人中时，我们有一个人以前是老师。我们还有一个人以前是身体健康护士，可能你可以直接从硕士学位申请并获得你选择的博士课程的名额，但也可能你需要做一些事情，让你更多地接触到合格的心理学家。关于切实可行步骤的第三步是关于其中一些途径的负担能力。当然，Sam与我的谈话，我们思考助理
psychologist roles are affordable for anybody, especially older applicants is a really useful watch or listen. Okay. Our third consideration area is the effort. And we need to think about acknowledging that, but also hopefully inspiring you too. So it is a challenge. You know, I get that.
心理学家角色对任何人，特别是年长的申请者来说是否负担得起，是一个非常有用的观看或收听内容。好的。我们的第三个考虑领域是努力。我们需要考虑承认这一点，但也希望激励你。所以这是一个挑战。你知道，我明白。
I absolutely, you know, bow down to that. It's a lot, you know, I get that. I absolutely, you know, bow down to that. It's a lot, you know, if you're thinking about doing a master's or an undergraduate course, you know, some sort of conversion, you know, really taking your career in a different direction from where you are now, that can feel a lot. It can feel daunting, you know, it's tricky, but I think it's worth it, you know, if you've got that idea,
我绝对，你知道，向这一点致敬。这很多，你知道，如果你在考虑攻读硕士或本科课程，你知道，某种转换，你知道，真正把你的职业生涯从你现在的地方带向不同的方向，那可能会感觉很多。这可能会让人望而生畏，你知道，这很棘手，但我认为这是值得的，你知道，如果你有那个想法，
if you're feeling unfulfilled in what you're doing currently, really speaking as someone who vibrantly and passionately loves being a qualified psychologist fills me up, you know, fills my cup. I love it and I want you to feel similarly fulfilled in your career too, whatever that might be. So it is a lot of effort but it might be really that you're investing in your future self and and this you know your children as well or the people around you. You're showing them what can be done when you when you need to start afresh or that you deserve to to be happy, you deserve to thrive, you deserve to have this, you deserve to thrive, you deserve
如果你对目前所做的事情感到不满足，真正以一个充满活力和热情地热爱成为一名合格心理学家的人的身份发言，这让我感到充实，你知道，填满了我的杯子。我喜欢它，我也希望你在你的职业生涯中感到同样的满足，无论那可能是什么。所以这需要付出很多努力，但可能你确实是在投资未来的自己，以及这，你知道，你的孩子，或者你周围的人。你正在向他们展示当你需要重新开始时可以做什么，或者你值得快乐，你值得茁壮成长，你值得拥有这个，你值得茁壮成长，你值得
to have this time for yourself, maybe especially if you had your children earlier or if life was complicated and chaotic when you were younger, but you found more predictability, you found more kind of solid steps and you've built a life around yourself that supports you now to optimally engage, to begin to think about what might make you happy. You know, maybe you've got those things in place now that you didn't have when you were younger and why shouldn't you use those as a springboard to, you know, to get somewhere fabulous for your future. So our fourth consideration is really thinking about balancing our lives as
拥有这段属于你自己的时间，也许特别是如果你早早有了孩子，或者如果你年轻时生活复杂而混乱，但你找到了更多的可预测性，你找到了更多坚实的步骤，并且你在自己周围建立了一种生活，现在支持你以最佳方式参与，开始思考什么能让你快乐。你知道，也许你现在已经具备了那些你年轻时没有的东西，为什么不利用它们作为跳板，你知道，去为你未来获得一些美妙的东西呢。所以我们的第四个考虑因素是真正思考平衡我们的生活，作为
perhaps older applicants. And I feel like I really resonate with this topic because I'm 43 now. And it really gets me thinking about what would I be doing if I wasn't a qualified psychologist? And I think I would be like, well, I'd be the number one listener to this podcast. I would be my own biggest fan. I'd be commenting on all of my social posts.
也许是年长的申请者。我觉得我真的对这个话题产生了共鸣，因为我现在43岁了。这真的让我思考，如果我不是一名合格的心理学家，我会做什么？我想我会像，好吧，我会是这个播客的头号听众。我会是我自己最大的粉丝。我会评论我所有的社交帖子。
I'd be like, oh, Marianne. So please feel free to be my groupie if that's helpful as well. You can come and follow me on all of my social platforms where I am Dr. Marianne Trent. But you know, I love to know more about you. I love to know why this content resonates with you. I love to see your comments on YouTube. I love to know why this content resonates with you. I love to see your comments on YouTube,
我会像，哦，Marianne。所以如果这有帮助的话，请随意成为我的粉丝。你可以来关注我所有的社交平台，我是Dr. Marianne Trent。但你知道，我喜欢更多地了解你。我喜欢知道为什么这些内容会引起你的共鸣。我喜欢在YouTube上看到你的评论。我喜欢知道为什么这些内容会引起你的共鸣。我喜欢在YouTube上看到你的评论，
I love to see your likes, I love it when you say how inspiring this content is and you know the same goes for the books as well. I love seeing your reviews of the clinical psychologist collective, of the aspiring psychologist collective, of the grief collective, of an autistic anthology and of talking heads. So if those books have meant something to you please do take a moment to leave me a review on Amazon or Goodreads. So I think you know what we learned about from Rose's episode was really thinking about how you can support older applicants, you know how you can acknowledge that they might have some additional struggles, some additional know, how you can acknowledge that they might have some additional struggles, some additional challenges, how you can be a really great friend, a really
我喜欢看到你的点赞，我喜欢当你提到这些内容是多么鼓舞人心时，你知道，书籍也是如此。我喜欢看到你们对《临床心理学家集体》、《有抱负的心理学家集体》、《悲伤集体》、《自闭症选集》和《谈话头》的评论。所以如果这些书对你有意义，请花点时间在亚马逊或Goodreads上给我留个评论。所以我认为，你知道，我们从Rose那一集学到的是真正思考你如何支持年长的申请者，你知道，你如何承认他们可能有一些额外的挣扎，一些额外的挑战，你如何能成为一个非常好的朋友，一个非常
great colleague to somebody who is an older applicant, you know, how you could think about what social events you're creating and whether it kind of matches with bedtimes for children or kind of getting home for supporting parents, maybe ask them to help you to plan something that kind of gives them the best chance of being able to engage and take part. But you might well need to be a time management ninja. And you know, I think absolutely when I was training, my experiences were those with children
好的同事，给一个年长的申请者，你知道，你如何思考你正在创造什么样的社交活动，以及它是否与孩子的就寝时间相匹配，或者是否能赶回家支持父母，也许请他们帮你计划一些事情，这能给他们最好的机会去参与。但你可能确实需要成为一名时间管理忍者。而且，你知道，我认为绝对在我培训时，我的那些有孩子的经历
would kind of have a tendency to go out to the library or to a coffee shop to get work done and Really made sure they used that time incredibly effectively to get those essays done to get things written Often ahead of time so they knew it was done They knew it was done to the best of their ability Whereas someone like me who had all the time in the world and often didn't have a partner certainly until the second year, you know, I just I'd get the same amount of work done but in a way longer time because I allowed myself more procrastination. So it's likely that this is going to hyper focus you if you are an older applicant because
往往会去图书馆或咖啡店完成工作，并且确实确保他们非常有效地利用那段时间来完成那些论文，把事情写出来，通常是提前完成，所以他们知道它完成了。他们知道它是以他们最好的能力完成的。而像我这样拥有所有时间，并且通常没有伴侣，当然直到第二年，你知道，我只是，我会在更长的时间内完成同样多的工作，因为我允许自己更多的拖延。所以很可能如果你是一名年长的申请者，这会让你高度专注，因为
you might well have more things that you've got to compartmentalize into your life. So self-care, looking after yourself is really important. Still important that you've got time and money to eat, gotta be able to move that lovely body of yours if you are physically able to do so because I honestly believe that really does keep us so well. And I think the power of asking for help,
你可能确实有更多的事情需要划分到你的生活中。所以自我保健，照顾好自己非常重要。仍然重要的是你有时间和金钱去吃饭，如果你身体允许的话，必须能够移动你那可爱的身体，因为我真心相信这确实让我们保持得很好。而且我认为寻求帮助的力量，
you know, from your community, from those around you, from your friends, from your family, it's okay to draw down on that as well as give back to people, which is something you may have been doing for the last few years. I'll pick those up for you from the school run, I'll do that for you, come around, drop them off, that's fine. But it's okay to ask for help as well. And people are not mind readers. They don't know that you might want them to pick up your child or to keep them for an hour or so after school.
你知道，从你的社区，从你周围的人，从你的朋友，从你的家人，从那里汲取帮助是可以的，就像回馈他人一样，这是你过去几年可能一直在做的事情。我会帮你从学校接他们，我会为你做那个，过来，把他们放下，那没问题。但寻求帮助也是可以的。而且人们不是读心者。他们不知道你可能希望他们接你的孩子，或者在放学后让他们待一个小时左右。
But if you ask for what you want, you are so much more likely to have your needs met. And similarly with your partner as well, actually, would it be okay if we thought about what days I cooked, what days you cooked? Because that actually will really free me up to do my masters, to do my essays, to think about doing what I need to do
但如果你要求你想要的，你更有可能满足你的需求。同样与你的伴侣也是如此，实际上，如果我们考虑我哪天做饭，你哪天做饭，这可以吗？因为那实际上真的会让我腾出时间来做我的硕士学位，做我的论文，思考做我需要做的事情
in a way that gives me that protected time. So I think our fifth point is thinking about encouragement. You are uniquely qualified, you know, you've got the wisdom,, you've got the wisdom, hopefully you've got the resilience, you've got that determination in being an older applicant, which is going to be such a key asset to yourself, but also to those that you work alongside and to the clients that you work with as well. You're going to be a source of inspiration, you know?
以一种给我那种受保护时间的方式。所以我认为我们的第五点是思考鼓励。你是独特合格的，你知道，你拥有智慧，你拥有智慧，希望你拥有韧性，你拥有作为年长申请者的那种决心，这将是你自己的一项关键资产，但也对你与之共事的人以及你与之共事的客户也是如此。你将成为灵感的源泉，你知道吗？
At any time, somebody can decide to turn their career in a different direction and that they matter, you know? That their needs for fulfillment are important. This, you know, this psychology career of ours, it isn't just a job, you know? I, for me, like I said, I find it a privilege but it's a calling. I love, I love talking to people. I love helping people to alleviate distress in their lives and to find balance and perspective and
在任何时候，某人都可以决定将他们的职业生涯转向不同的方向，并且他们很重要，你知道吗？他们对成就感的需求很重要。这，你知道，我们的心理学职业，它不仅仅是一份工作，你知道吗？我，对我来说，就像我说的，我发现这是一种特权，但它是一种使命。我喜欢，我喜欢与人交谈。我喜欢帮助人们减轻生活中的痛苦，找到平衡和视角以及
compassion and to acknowledge, you know, what they've been through, why it's had an impact on them, to help them to make sense of what they've experienced and to acknowledge you know what they've been through, why it's had an impact on them, to help them to make sense of what they've experienced and to know that it doesn't always need to be this way. Like I honestly feel like I've just got the best job in the world and you know if you don't feel like that currently I want you to feel like that about what you do whatever it is. So you're not starting from scratch, you are starting with all of your experience and you get to build upon that. Let's think about your experience, your wisdom, your years of training, experience, your, you know, your parenting, your being a friend,
同情心，并承认，你知道，他们经历了什么，为什么它对他们产生了影响，帮助他们理解他们所经历的事情，并承认，你知道，他们经历了什么，为什么它对他们产生了影响，帮助他们理解他们所经历的事情，并知道它并不总是需要这样。就像我真心觉得我刚刚得到了世界上最好的工作，你知道，如果你目前没有那种感觉，我希望你对你所做的事情有那种感觉，无论那是什么。所以你不是从零开始，你是带着你所有的经验开始，并且你可以在此基础上建立。让我们思考你的经验，你的智慧，你多年的培训，经验，你的，你知道，你的育儿，你作为朋友，
your being a sibling, your being a child. That is all things that you bring to the table that helps make you relatable, that helps you to to draw down on your wisdom. Also a really great psychologist, colleague and friend too. You'll get to be a supervisor, you'll get to inspire the next generation regardless of their age. Of course in one of our episodes we were speaking about how it feels to be supervised by somebody that's younger than you or that you're a similar age to and that's all useful, grist for the mill as they say, really important reflection points and it's okay. We don't necessarily need to think about people as an age but you know it's okay to be less experienced than somebody that is younger than
你作为兄弟姐妹，你作为孩子。这些都是你带到桌面上来的东西，有助于让你变得容易相处，有助于你汲取你的智慧。也是一位非常棒的心理学家、同事和朋友。你将成为一名督导，你将激励下一代，无论他们的年龄如何。当然，在我们的一集里，我们谈到了被比你年轻或与你年龄相仿的人监督是什么感觉，这都是有用的，正如他们所说的，磨坊的谷物，非常重要的反思点，这没关系。我们不一定需要把人看作一个年龄，但你知道，比一个比你年轻的人经验少是可以的，
you because they got there quicker or they've had more opportunities, they've had more privilege perhaps. So yeah, don't let your age and your beliefs about your age and maybe, you know, some embarrassment or some shame or, you know, your thoughts around imposter syndrome, you know? Get in your way. Don't try and... Don't let chips on your shoulder get in your way don't try don't let chips on your shoulder get in your way either like if you want to do this then please do let
因为他们更快地到达了那里，或者他们有更多的机会，他们可能拥有更多的特权。所以是的，不要让你的年龄和你对年龄的信念，也许，你知道，一些尴尬或一些羞耻，或者，你知道，你围绕冒名顶替综合症的想法，你知道吗？挡你的路。不要试图……不要让肩上的筹码挡你的路，也不要让肩上的筹码挡你的路，如果你想做这个，那么请务必
me know I'd love to know what this episode has evoked for you please do if watching on YouTube let me know in the comments like subscribe you know share this episode with your friends it would be so appreciated I'd love your stories as well regardless whatever your age I'd love your stories as well, regardless, whatever your age, I'd love to know your individual story, you know, why it matters to you, why you started your career in psychology and what age you were when you started it.
让我知道，我很想知道这一集为你唤起了什么。请务必，如果是在YouTube上观看，请在评论中告诉我，点赞，订阅，你知道，与你的朋友分享这一集，那将不胜感激。我也很喜欢你的故事，无论你的年龄如何，我也很喜欢你的故事，无论你的年龄如何，我很想知道你的个人故事，你知道，为什么它对你很重要，为什么你开始了你的心理学职业，以及你开始时多大。
So I hope that's been really useful. If it is your time and you're ready for the next step, please do consider the aspiring psychologist membership where we will help you to develop the skills and the abilities and the reflections that you need to be able to reflect, to be able to formulate, to be able to think confidently and talk confidently about research, to be able to separate a theory from a model and to you know to be able to be a really lovely, empathic, thoughtful clinician. You can join from just £30 a month with no minimum term. If you wanted to join for a longer
所以我希望这非常有帮助。如果是你的时间，你准备好迈出下一步了，请务必考虑“有抱负的心理学家”会员计划，我们将帮助你发展你需要的技能、能力和反思，以便能够反思，能够制定，能够自信地思考并自信地谈论研究，能够将理论与模型分开，并且你知道，能够成为一名非常可爱、有同理心、体贴的临床医生。你可以每月仅需30英镑加入，没有最低期限。如果你想加入更长
period of time and pay for six months upfront, you would get a free 30-minute one-to-one with me. If you're like, you know, I'm in it for the long haul, I'm going to be here for a while, you can join for 12 months upfront, and and you then get either your choice of two 30-minute one-to-ones or one one-hour one-to-one where we can really go to town on you know getting a bespoke plan in place for for you whether that's scrutinizing applications whether that's practicing interview questions whether that's really thinking about tailor making your career and how we're gonna get you to where you want to be. There's also loads of inspiration in the clinical psychologist collective book and the aspiring psychologist
一段时间并预付六个月，你将获得一次免费的30分钟一对一与我交流。如果你觉得，你知道，我准备长期投入，我会在这里待一段时间，你可以预付12个月，然后你就可以选择两次30分钟的一对一或一次一小时的一对一，我们可以真正深入地，你知道，为你制定一个定制计划，无论是审查申请，还是练习面试问题，还是真正思考量身定制你的职业生涯，以及我们将如何让你到达你想去的地方。在《临床心理学家集体》书和《有抱负的心理学家》
collective book too. Then let this be your guide With this podcast that you'll set You'll be on your way to being qualified It's the Aspiring Psychologist Podcast With Dr. Mary Antrim My name is Yana and I'm a trainee psychological wellbeing practitioner. I read the clinical psychologist collective book. I found it really interesting about all the different stories and how people got to become a clinical psychologist. It just amazed me how many different routes there are to get there and there's no perfect way to become one and this kind of filled me with confidence that no I'm not doing it
集体书中也有大量的灵感。那么让这成为你的指南。有了这个播客，你将设置，你将走上成为合格心理学家的道路。这是《有抱负的心理学家播客》，我是Mary Antrim博士。我的名字是Yana，我是一名心理健康从业者实习生。我读了《临床心理学家集体》这本书。我发现关于所有不同的故事以及人们如何成为临床心理学家的内容非常有趣。这让我惊讶于有这么多不同的途径可以到达那里，没有完美的途径成为一名心理学家，这让我充满了信心，不，我没有做
wrong and put less pressure on myself. So if you're feeling a bit uneasy about becoming a clinical psychologist I definitely recommend this just to put yourself at ease and everything will be okay. But trust me you will not put the book down once you start. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
错，并减轻了我的压力。所以如果你对成为一名临床心理学家感到有点不安，我绝对推荐这个，只是为了让你安心，一切都会好起来的。但相信我，一旦你开始，你就不会放下这本书。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来留下评论。